شهر 10 من الحرب في اوكرانيا ولا نظيره
لهدوء لهدوء الاجواء جوا واردن وبالاصح لا
علامه فارقه تنتشي بان نهايه الصراع بين
موسكو وكاف تلوح في الافق القريب بل ان
معارك ضاريه تحتدم تاره وتهدا تاره اخرى
لكنها لا تؤثر في سخونه الحرب فها هي
بريطانيا تختاروا لنفسها ان تكون اول دوله
ترسل دبابات غربيه غربيه الصنع الى
اوكرانيا بل وتعهد رئيس الوزراء
البريطانيه ريشي سوناك بارسال 14 دبابه
قتاليه من طراز تشالنجر 2 الى كاف خلال
الاسابيع المقبله ومن المتوقع ان يتبعها
بل ان يتبعها قرابه الثلاثين من المدافع
ذاتيه الدفع من طراز اي اس 19 يديرها خمسه
من المدعيين سوناك اسر ايضا على ضرو تدريب
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه على استخدام
الدبابات والمدافع تلك ذهبت صحيفه ميرور
البريطانيه ابعد من ذلك بالتاكيد على انك
ستحصل من لندن على ما يصل الى اربع
مروحيات من نوع باتشي لكن وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه نفت هذا الموضوع في بيان رسميا
[موسيقى]
ربما يكون النفي البريطاني لموضوع تزويد
اكياس بالاباتشي مراعات للخطوط الحمراء
لان مروحيات
اكثر تقدما والقادر على تدمير اهداف
متعدده في ثواني اما بالنسبه لتشالنجر 2
فتصفها الشركه المصنعه بانها دبابه القتال
الرئيسه الاكثر موثوقيه للعالم والتي لم
يستطع العدو يوما ما تدميرها ويمكنها
اصابته ثمانيه اهداف مختلفه في الدقيقه
الواحده دعم لم يدخره سوناك بل انه كان قد
اكده مع الرئيس الاوكراني
في اتصال هاتفي اعرب فيه عن طموحي بلاده
في تكثيف الدعم لاوكرانيا عسكريه
بالشكل الذي يؤمن لها النصر والسلام في
النهايه
ابتويد
لمحادثه التي اجراها مع رئيس زيرانسكي
وسيصدر وزير الدفاع اعلانا كاملا الى مجلس
العموم الاسبوع المقبل دعمنا للشعب
الاوكراني في دفاعه عن النفس ضد العدوان
الروسي لا يتزعزع واعتقد ان البيان او
الاعلان الذي ادلى به رئيس الوزراء هو
انعكاس لذلك
كان هذا هو الاعتراف البريطاني لكن الامر
بطبيعه الحال لا يتوقف على لندن